so I saw you on uh talk with Steve
Harvey a bunch of times and it was I
always loved it uh one thing just sticks
in my head from something he said as
advice that if you and your partner your
spouse are you know if there's a fight
there's a difficult thing you have to
deal with keep that to yourself don't
talk to anyone else like that's a little
like a what does he say like a two arm
Circle or something whatever the
expression is but basically resolve it
all internally don't like when you face
the world you have a front of like don't
take sides against the family
yeah yes what like it all boils down to
Godfather it all everything boils down
to Godfather references it really does
in True Romance yeah you don't take
sides against the family you don't you
don't you don't show that weakness to
the world I I mean again I don't know
that I don't know that Steve en cander
would say you shouldn't discuss it with
your own therapist you know but but I
think what he's saying is don't project
it out to the world don't share that
because I I think you know it will it
can change the way people view your
relationship which then will change the
way you view your
relationship you know and and so I I
think um don't run Reckless when it
comes to your that primary
relationship don't run your mouth
recklessly yeah it's one of the things
uh I mentioned to you Offline that you
know my now close friend Joe Rogan I've
never heard him ever speak negatively of
his wife it's always like super positive
how awesome of a person she is and that
to me has always been an inspiration to
do the same for every everybody in my
life to always speak positively about
them is uh that has a probably a
virtuous spiral effect I'm sure like I
that's that's probably because he has a
great wife and he has a great wife in
part because of that yeah like I I I
think it's clear that he's in her corner
and cheering for her it's clear she's
cheering for him like they they have
it's not like Joe Rogan's not a man who
has opportunity I mean he's surrounded
by UFC ring girls for God's sakes like
this is a guy who has all the
opportunity in the world and he seems to
be quite a fan of his wife and that is
you know that's a superpower like that's
a real thing now the question is is you
know he doesn't seem to talk about it
like oh I got to really work at that
yeah you know and that's not a man who's
afraid to talk about what he works at
you know he's pretty honest about man
yeah I got to work really hard to stay
in sh I got to work really hard to be
able to do this like yeah I'm not good
at memorizing that it takes time yeah
but I've never heard him say like oh
marriage is a lot of work like and I
think that's to his credit because it it
seems like they're enjoying that and
it's also not incredibly public like
it's not something most people couldn't
pick her out of a lineup he kept it
private for many years and just because
it's a private Joy it's a private like
deep meaningful intimate partnership
that's interesting that's also an
inspiration it doesn't not everything
about your life has to be this like like
look at me I'm happy like uh I'm in a
happy relationship everything is
wonderful especially that I I I think
there is something
about the womb like cocoon like Joy you
know of like love you know when you're
just tucked in snuggled in like just
pressed against each other with that
like that that's such a you know like a
it's just the two of you yeah and that's
lovely you know and that's such a a good
thing and I I I like we were just dying
for connection you know and and that
connection is
so big it's so everything you know one
of my earliest psychedelic experiences
probably when I was a
teenager but a theme that's been
persistent in every psychedelic
experience I've ever had is this idea of
like everything is connection everything
is being pressed to someone and with
them you know like the warmth of human
connection like I one of the reasons I I
enjoy listening to your work and your
perspective has always been that I I
think at the core you see connection and
love and and I think for
me from my earliest experiences with
psychedelics at you know 16
17 I was very attuned to that I was very
much that was put on my radar by
psychedelics and just stayed part of my
Consciousness forever and I I think I
had a 30-some year break from
psychedelics but it was like when I came
back to it I went oh yeah it's still
there that's still the core of
everything is connection I mean it's
fascinating How Deeply you value
connection how empathic you are that you
would be doing what you're doing which
is uh or or is it not
intive no I think it's it's actually why
I'm well suited for what I do I think
what I do is I have to learn the story
of my client and know it and feel it
very deeply and I have to feel it in a
very human way that's very compassionate
to this person and then I have to feel
it and understand it in a way that's
incredibly antagonistic to it so I can
Shore up
defenses so I have to I have to
feel this person's story and feelings
from every possible angle because every
one of them is a vulnerability and every
one of them is a potential strength and
a potential defense and so I I actually
think it's my number one other than
extemporaneous speaking ability it is my
number one job tool is the ability to
radically empathize and to put myself in
the emotional state of someone in its
best possible light and its worst
possible light so that I can see again
the defense and I can see the
vulnerability but I mean so that's
beautifully put but also just to to Bear
witness to this connection broken in the
yeah in most dramatic way over and over
and over and over that part is hard but
I was a hospice volunteer for many many
years when I first got out of
college and it really showed me a lot
about you know what
is what is sadness what is tragic and
what is just inevitable Decay what is
pain and Decay like we all die like we
we play a game you can't win to the
utmost and so if we know the answer to
all of this is you're going to die then
what do we do with the rest of that time
if all your stuff is just stuff it's
just going to go to the you know the
money is going to go like everything's
your looks is going to go your
everything's going to go Love's going to
end one way or the then what are we
doing you know and I again I think it's
love and connection but what I'm doing
for a living is helping and I don't look
at it as what I'm doing is helping
people beat the crap out of each other I
look at it as I'm I'm trying to help a
client build their post- divorce life to
to sort of Rise From the Ashes of that
which has fallen apart and move on to
the next chapter and refocus
and have the things they need
financially emotionally whatever it
might be interpersonally in terms of
with their kids and so for me it's it's
actually a job that is very consistent
with my desire to build connection and
to be empathetic and witnessing the ases
doesn't make you cynical about the whole
thing of love no because again you know
56% of marriag is end in divorce but 84%
are remarried within 5 years like we
keep doing it over and over again and
that's a good thing that's I think it is
a good thing the mess of it the the
absurdity of it the hypocrisy of it
that's a something um that's something
beautiful about that well it's just the
return is so great on the investment you
know like the listen man I've had more
than one dog yeah like when I when my
dog died the first dog I had died I
remember when I'm never gonna love again
I'm done I'm done with this I will never
expose myself to this kind of pain again
I'll never have to take the dog bed and
put it in the closet and
like and then some friend called me and
said we have an adoption event can you
just watch this dog for 24 hours and
then we'll take him you know we just
need you know and I went yeah all right
I'll watch a dog for the night you know
and this dog come in say oh he has M
he's not going I got another dog he
walked in and my heart went yeah I got a
dog and now that dog is 13 years old and
his eyes are clouded outy and he doesn't
go up the stairs real well and he's
going to break my
heart and and I wouldn't change that for
the world I'm still there um I'm still
struggling for the second one I've I
lost a dog and it broke my heart and
yeah but and you and you'll
never you'll never lose that pain but I
promise you your heart has an infinite
capacity for the kind of love you felt
with that dog and you'll never feel a
love that replaces the whole like there
will never be another Buster for
me but there was
cabba and like you know what like and
when he's gone there will never be
another one of him but you know what
like when when that stupid puppy that
was five months old stumbled in I went I
guess I'm going to do this again and you
know what I'm so glad I'm so glad and I
know by the way I know now because and
that's where I I I've said like you know
it's that Joseph Brodsky poem you know a
song like I wish I knew no astronomy
when stars appear like I wish I didn't
know the pain but you know what like I I
don't care I don't care and I believe we
don't care I again I think there's
something to that if something hurts so
badly and you go I'm going to do it
again I'm going to do it that it must be
of value it must be of real value
there's also uh different perspective on
it uh that pain so there's that uh from
Lou the show of this interaction with an
old man with Lou CK and he says that uh
cuz Lou is mourning the loss of uh got
split up he got dumped or whatever and
he's mourning the loss of that partner
of of love and the old man says um that
that is the best part like missing the
love is still love the the bad the real
bad part is when you forget it when you
when the pain Fades and it's all gone
but the pain is actually a kind of
celebration of the love you have course
well the opposite of Love isn't hate the
opposite of Love is indifference yeah
there's no question about that I mean it
hate is a passionate emotion love is a
passionate emotion but and and there is
a school of thought that says that only
unfulfilled love can be truly
romantic but I I believe that it's what
I think I learned from hospice is that I
I I think for me knowing the
impermanence is is the thing you know
it's the key yeah it's finite and
eventually it's going to be over and so
like that intensifies the feeling that
that's when you can have Pure Love
without the drama dogs are for me a
great example and again I don't know
what it all means right existentially
but I just feel like they have that that
kind of love has to be here to teach us
something and I I feel like the fact
that they're so amazing and just so
loving and so wonderful and the bond we
feel is so amazing and deep and doesn't
require a lot of
Maintenance and yet it's so finite like
it's just this short little
lifespan and I feel like that there's
just such a lesson there you know
there's so much there to unpack about
the nature of connection and loss
and you know that that that your heart
has this infinite capacity like when
you're I'm telling you when when my dog
died when Buster died I remember I
thinking with certainty I will never do
this again because I'll never love that
way again I'll Never Love A dog the way
I love this dog and it's just not true
that's just not true like they you you
have this infinite capacity and and it's
that makes it scary actually actually
because like right now there's so many
people you could love there's so many
dogs you could love like there's so much
out there and it's requires a certain
bravery and tremendous amount of risk to
do it you know and um a commitment
because I I think to really experience
love is you just dive in because there
is a huge number of people but to really
like I mean you you have to
like really
um dive into the full complexity the
full range of another human being yeah
which is hard because we don't even I
don't know that we even feel comfortable
diving into the full range of
ourselves